texas and mississippi open back up and
the democrats and media lose their
ever-loving minds plus
andrew cuomo says he's not going
anywhere i'm ben shapiro this is the
venture pure show
[Music]
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
it's time to stand up to bigtech protect
your data at expressvpn.com
we'll get to all the news of the day in
just one moment first the word is out
people are abandoning that overpriced
wireless carrier they are flocking to
pure talk for the same coverage but at a
fraction of the price that is correct if
you're with verizon a t or t-mobile
switching to pure talk could save your
family over 800
a year and switching is really easy you
can keep your phone keep your number
or get huge discounts on the latest
iphones and androids right now
you can get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data for just 30 bucks a month
and
if you go over on data they don't charge
you for it there's a reason pure talk is
the highest rated wireless company by
consumer affairs
stop giving your money to overpriced
wireless carriers and start
saving money right now a lot of phone
companies will intentionally try to
confuse you exactly what kind of
coverage you're getting
for the money that you're paying at not
so with pure talk you know exactly what
you're getting again that's unlimited
talk text
and six gigs of data for just 30 bucks a
month and if you go over on the data
they're not going to charge you so you
have nothing to lose
from your cell phone so i'll pound 250
say ben shapiro you'll save 50
off your very first month that is pound
250 say
ben shapiro puretalk is simply smarter
wireless go check them out right now
dial pound 250 and say my name then your
shapiro and get 50
off your very first month and you're
gonna save hundreds down the road
alrighty so
texas and mississippi have now opened
back up and people
seem to be very upset about this they
seem very very angry
that certain states in america are
opening back up wider than other states
and i gotta say i don't think this has a
lot to do with science i think this has
a lot to do with jealousy and
a one-size-fits-all mentality about what
works
and this comes from the public health
establishment the
vaunted dr faucis out there the same
media proclaimed that andrew cuomo was
fantastic
at this and gavin newsom was fantastic
at this well it turns out that a lot of
states approach this thing a lot of
different ways
and there are a lot of different results
and some of those results resembled each
other even when the methods to get to
those results did not resemble
one another as i've been pointing out
for at this point months
california and florida have very similar
death per million rates
florida has the second oldest population
in america after maine which means they
really have the oldest population
because maine has eight people and
california has the fifth youngest
population
california has been shut down for a year
florida's been wide open since the
summer
and yet the public health professionals
they will tell you that florida has been
irresponsible and terrible
and now that texas and mississippi are
opening back up they're saying oh well
you know
that they can't do that that's just
terrible and we're getting the scare
tactics so
you see all these reports today about
all of these coveted variants that are
going to
inevitably wipe through the population
the problem is we don't actually know
that at this point
we know that the vaccines have some
efficacy against most of the variants
that we have seen
thus far and we don't have enough
evidence thus far as to what the actual
effect of the variance is going to be on
vaccinated populations
which is why we are rushing to vaccinate
people right now
nonetheless the media are fully invested
in panic mode and remain invested in
panic mode because
number one it's good for business and
number two they're invested in the idea
that centralized government is the
solution to all ills
because once the government has
centralized all power then the
government can do everything you want
the government to do
every crisis is an opportunity as rahm
emanuel barack obama's former chief of
staff
and former mayor of chicago once said so
reuters is reporting that chris murray
a university of washington disease
expert whose projections on cover 19
infections and deaths are closely
followed worldwide
is changing his assumptions about the
course of the pandemic murray had until
recently been hopeful that the discovery
of several affected vaccines could help
countries achieve herd immunity
or nearly eliminate transmission through
a combination of inoculation and
previous infection but in the last month
data from a vaccine trail in south
africa showed not only that a rapidly
spreading covet variant could dampen the
effect of the vaccine it could also
evade natural immunity in people who had
previously been infected well if that is
the case
then you literally can't do anything
you've now talked about
a disease that you cannot create
immunity to right it just comes back
around it's like a common cold
it just comes back around and the
vaccine ain't gonna work on it so what
exactly is supposed to do lock yourself
in your house for the rest of time
he says i couldn't sleep he's the
director of the institute for health
metrics and evaluation remember the ihme
model which is really really off in the
early days it's basically a garbage ring
garbage drop model it just takes
prior data puts it in there and then
makes assumptions makes the assumptions
clear and then tosses out
what it thinks will be the future
sometimes it's right and sometimes it's
wrong it certainly was not the best
model
that was out there a new consensus is
emerging according to scientists
according to reuters interviews many
describes how the breakthrough late last
year of two vaccines with around 95
efficacy against coca-19 had initially
sparked hope the virus could be largely
contained
similar to the way measles has been but
they say now it looks like this is going
to be an endemic virus
it'll circulate in communities and it
could cause a significant burden of
illness and death for years to come
as a result said scientists people could
expect to continue to take measures such
as routine mask wearing and avoiding
crowded places during covet-19 surges
especially for people
at high risk dr fauci says i would still
want to wear a mask if there was a
variant out there all you need is one
little flick of a variant sparking
another surge and there goes your
prediction
about when life gets back to normal
murray says that if the south african
variant or similar mutants continue to
spread rapidly
the number of coven 19 cases resulting
in hospitalization or death this coming
winter could be four times higher
than the flu now again it's important to
understand base rates here four times
higher than the flu
does not mean that we are looking at
black plague type numbers
the flu is indeed a dangerous disease
but nobody has ever shut down society
for the flu we know that this particular
disease has been something like five
times more deadly than the flu and we
also know that it spreads
much more widely than the flu so if we
now we are saying that the the
amount of death total not the deadliness
the amount of death is four times that
of the flu
without with a virus that is much more
contagious and there's not really a way
of stopping it
the only time that people are actively
going to engage in the sort of measures
we've been engaging in is if the health
system is on the verge of being
overwhelmed then we actually don't have
evidence that that is the case anywhere
in america right now
it may happen and if that happens then
maybe we'll start taking these measures
but in reality most people particularly
young healthy people
are not going to stop their lives stop
dating stop going to parties stop going
to ball games
because a disease that mainly kills
people over the age of 70
is still out there and is coming around
seasonally especially since you have no
cure for it
so what exactly do you expect people to
do people are going to act using their
rational minds in other words people are
going to use their rational
self-interest to determine what sort of
risk they're willing to undergo
right if you have parents who are 80
they're probably not going to go to a
ballgame for a while
if the variants are still out there but
if you're 30 are you going to go to a
ballgame
probably are you going to go shoulder to
shoulder with someone to an event
probably because you'll get it and
you'll be fine in
the vast fast fast vast majority of
cases again the death rates for people
who are between the ages like 20 and 65
those death rates
are a fraction in one thousand i mean
we're talking about like three in a
thousand four in a thousand at the upper
end
because the overall total death rate on
this thing is like five in one thousand
and that includes people
in the upper age brackets where you're
talking about like five and a hundred or
six and a hundred dying
from this thing the ihme their current
forecast
assumes there will be an additional 62
000 us deaths and 690
000 global deaths from coveted 19 by
june 1st that model does include
assumptions about vaccination rates as
well
as the transmissibility of south african
and brazilian variants so here is the
point
there will always be new covered
variants out there
there will always be new things that are
happening in the world of health
the idea of a top-down government
mandate that radically changes
individual decision making
that is unjustified and is perfectly
unjustifiable when
the only thing you can say is that there
are new risks out there we know there
are new risks out there it was one thing
when you were saying you didn't know
what the death rates were on this virus
where you really didn't know if it was
the black plague you didn't know if it
was going to wipe out entire classrooms
of elementary school students
but now we know we know the vectors of
these diseases we know which populations
they tend to hit the hardest we know how
to protect those populations
and we know what people are willing to
do in order to shield themselves from
risk
people are not going to live life this
way and yet when states reopen when they
say you need to use your own individual
reason
then the left gets very angry because
undergirding all of this is a two
is a two-fold proposition proposition
number one is that it is very good
for centralized governments to have
enormous power over your life because
they know better than you
and that is the second proposition you
don't know how to handle your own life
on nearly any
metric you don't need you don't know how
to handle your your own personal
economics that is why we need to remove
money from you
and then supposedly give it back to you
later even though we won't with social
security it's why we need
to make sure that you're not going to
take care of your own health care we
need to provide health care for you we
the centralized government
you don't know how to educate your child
we're going to tell you how to educate
your child and
you don't know how to avoid death so we
are going to force you to wear a mask
right that that is the that is the
centralizing government
rationale behind so much of the debate
that is happening
right now i'll give you some stats to
show this is the case in just
one second first let's talk about the
fact that you don't want to go to the
auto parts store i mean first of all why
would you ever want to go to the auto
parts store you stand in line for a
really long time then you finally get to
the front of the line
and then ask a bunch of questions you
don't know the answer to finally you
figure out what part you need
and then they're like oh yeah we don't
have that we're gonna have to order that
online well you could just
do it online yourself because the
interwebs are great so why not head on
over to rockauto.com
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear like airlines do
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same exact parts
you know for example let's say you need
a delphi fg1456 fuel pump assembly for a
2005 to 2010 honda odyssey i just came
up with that off the top of my head
amazing like that well i'll tell you
what at an auto parts store it'll cost
you like 354 bucks that's the kind of
thing you can get at rock auto for 217
which is saving a lot of money
rockauto.com it's a family business
they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years head on
over to rockauto.com shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers and best of all
the prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same exact parts they've got
amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever need rockauto.com
head on over to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck and right shapiro in there how
did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you okay so
states are handling the covid variant
and kovid
situation very differently new york is
now thinking
about doing a a coveted passport
this would be very much like what israel
has been doing you need to show that
you've actually had the cover vaccine
in order to go into particular public
areas again i think there's a bad idea
because people are just going to start
forging these things
if you want access to something you're
just going to forge also it does create
a
two uh sort of two-level society in
which people who have
gotten the vaccine are allowed to do
things and people who have not gotten
vaccine are not allowed to do things
i will say that it does create the right
incentive which is to go get vaccinated
but what's the cut cutoff is the age cut
off 18
because again if you're 18 years old
you're really not not at high risk from
covid 19.
the proper solution here is that people
again should use their own reason and
they should go get the vaccine and we
should be encouraging them socially to
get the vaccine
if private businesses want to say if
madison's war garden wants to say listen
you can only come to a basketball game
if you get the vaccine
i think that is perfectly reasonable for
the entire city
to be testing out vaccine green cards uh
seems to raise serious liberty concerns
but the big story of the day really is
that texas and mississippi said we're
done with our mass mandates now
let me just remind you there are not
mass mandates
in some 15 states in the united states
and i'm going to read you those 15
states in the united states
these are the states that do not have a
mass mandate they don't mandate that you
have a mask
in public places on public property okay
these are the states and i'm also going
to give you their death per capita ratio
i'm going to give you where they rank
among the 51 u.s
states in and washington dc where do
they rank
okay so here is where these states rank
these are the ones without a mass
mandate now what you have been told is
that a mass mandate is the cure-all
you have you've heard that the mass
mandate is the answer to all of your
problems right joe biden more mask
and covered one way i mean it was
amazing right as soon as you put on
those math doesn't matter what kind of
mask you put a sock over your face with
a bra over your face doesn't matter
all the same now obviously this was
nonsense wearing an n95 is much more
effective
than wearing a sock right wearing a can
95 is much better than a neck gator
wearing these things properly is very
important not putting your hands all
over them that's very important but
we treated it as though if you put a
cloth mask on your face and re-wear it
every day
and this is going to be the answer to
all of your problems and if the state
mandates it that this is going to
radically change
things now here's the thing about
mandates when it comes to masks people
who want to wear the mask are going to
wear it people who don't want to wear it
are not going to wear it
that is the the reality of the situation
and as the rates of covet rise in a
particular community as we've seen from
the maps
the rate of mass quantum goes up in
other words people use
their actual reasonable self-assessment
of their risk
and then they make decisions so how does
that so what does that mean it means
that in states with a mandate
a lot of those states did really poorly
new york number two
in death per million ratio new jersey
number one in death per million ratio
okay here are the states that do not
have a mass mandate and remember i'm
i'm pointing this out because you're
going to hear democrats in one second
talk about how it is just
the worst thing you could possibly do to
remove a state mass mandate remember
removing a state mandate to wear a mask
is not a ban on wearing a mask
i understand that for the left there
seems to be only two categories
that which is mandatory and that which
is banned right those are the only two
categories there's no third category of
stuff you're allowed to do
it's just the stuff you must be forced
to do by the government and stuff that
you are forced not to do by the
government
and this is how people on the left tend
to think of the government the
government is there to do the good thing
so if you're gonna wear if we want you
to wear a mask we have to force you to
wear a mask
and if somebody says that they think
that you should have the ability not to
wear a mask
that's the same thing as them saying
they want you not to wear a mask not how
this works
if texas says we're not going to mandate
it that means exactly what it means
right which means they're not going to
punish people they're not going to find
people they're not going to jail people
they're not going to have a mass mandate
on the books
that doesn't mean that you on an
individual level can't wear a mask you
can anytime you want
you can decide where to go you can
determine if you don't want to go into a
business that has a lot of unmasked
people
and we make these sorts of decisions
every single day throughout our lives
do you go do you drive into a particular
area with a high crime rate
do you go out at a particular time of
night
when there are fewer when there are
fewer people out on the streets
where do you jog where do you send your
kids to school right these sort of risk
assessments
how fast do you drive which route do you
take all of these risk assessments are
part of your everyday life
we have evolved to make these risk
assessments sometimes we make good risk
assessments sometimes we make bad risk
assessments but the
purpose of freedom is so that you can
make those risk assessments according to
the left however you should not be
allowed to do this because you're stupid
so how have those states without a mass
mandate performed
because if the left is right what that
would mean is that when you don't have a
mass mandate everybody unmasks and then
everybody dies
i'm not kidding this is literally what
people on the left are saying so for
example
beta o'rourke is
back bro i mean ever since that that
texas freeze better living in this big
old house inheriting lots of money
kick flick bong rip baby
he says you know what if they if if
governor abbott says that we're allowed
to take off the mask
they want to kill us all bro let me tell
you something
i don't like that very much i mean it's
harshing my vibe
bro they literally want to sacrifice the
lives
of literal fellow texans or i don't know
for for political gain
to satisfy certain powerful interests
within the state
and this isn't hyperbole it's hard to
escape the conclusion that it's also a
cult of death
um you have extraordinarily
anti-democratic elements i mean look at
the insurrection on january 6
for for any proof you have
anti-government
elements literally running the
government of of the state of texas
and it almost i use the phrase failed
state because i think when you can't
guarantee the electricity the heat the
running water
the the public welfare and safety you
are about there by any classic
definition
uh it's not hyperbole bro it's a cult of
death
and let me tell you i've been out in the
desert man i've seen some things i ate
some new mexican
dirt raw after skateboarding let me tell
you my skateboard does not work well
on sand but bro it's a cult of death
it's like
literally human sacrifice i'm not going
to say i've seen human sacrifice brah
but if i had it would look exactly like
that it's a failed state man
by the way if you think that texas is a
failed state you might want to visit a
failed state one time
like the electrical grid broke that was
horrible people died
it was really really bad see the thing
about a failed state is that it never
was on
right the electrical grid goes down and
it stays down people eat dogs in the
streets for years on end
the the utter you want to talk about
privilege this guy is the is the
definition of privilege
and my goodness beto o'rourke what a
joke he is but
but that's the point right is that when
he says things like it's a cold they
want to kill us all
right if i say to you you're a free
human being you have the ability to
decide for yourself whether you want to
wear a mask or whether you don't want to
wear a mask
that is that is me saying that you
should go out and kill everybody
i mean it's me saying that i want a cult
of death
according to beta o'rourke so liberty is
a cult of death you being able to make
your own decisions your own risk
assessment
that is a cult of death complete with
human sacrifice
and everything by the way i just quick
note
i do love hearing about human sacrifice
from people who are the biggest
proponents of abortion on planet earth
tell me more about human sacrifice and
cults of death beta o'rourke captain
planned parenthood over there
okay but it's not just beto who's making
this case
it's idiots like michael moore in the
political
commentary sphere so michael moore
who is beginning to look more and more
like that guy who plays toodles
and hook gosh he's bobbles michael moore
he tweeted out texas we hear you you
didn't want to be part of our electrical
grid
and now you've removed your mask manta
and are allowing large crowds together
we hear you
covet is a hoax so you don't need our
precious vaccine we'll send it to people
who are saving lives by wearing masks
so um a few things here your precious
vaccine what did you do
does he work for the big pharmaceutical
companies i thought he doesn't like
those people also
under whose administration was the
covered vaccine developed all right that
would have been
trump's also saying that you want people
to be able to exercise individual
liberty does not mean those people
didn't get the vaccine in fact
one of the chief sort of draws of the
vaccine is that after you get the
vaccine you should be able to walk
around without a mask
there's a point that senator rand paul's
been making since he had colvin
saying i now have immunity i'm not
passing it to anyone i don't have to
wear a mask
he happens to be basically correct about
this okay so
but the the real underlying animus is
for the people of texas right
if you have a political viewpoint that
cuts toward liberty you should die
right that is what michael moore is
saying right there and beta o'rourke is
basically saying the same thing
if you are a person who believes that
individuals should make their own
decisions about their lives then this
means that you are part of a cult of
death who's involved in human sacrifice
because beto knows what's best for you
sure he didn't know enough to beat ted
cruz in a very competitive senate race
and sure he was on the cover of vanity
fair magazine
wearing the exact same outfit he always
wears on the campaign trail saying he
was born to run and then he proceeded to
lose sure he ended up in the new mexican
desert
eating dirt not kidding that's the thing
he did but beta o'rourke
yeah that guy he knows what's best for
you what an incredible human being
then there's joe biden who knows
absolutely what's best for you i mean
really knows
what's best for you and the way you can
tell that joe biden knows what's best
for you
is because he is not a sentient human
anymore joe biden is not he he is
he is a a basically joe biden is an
inanimate object
that occasionally lets words fall out of
its face uh
i'm sorry to tell you this but joe biden
is not all there again the attic is not
full
the lights are not all on the toaster is
not plugged in
there there's not a lot of wattage going
on here here is here is joe biden
suggesting that texas and mississippi if
you were moving mass mandate remember
abbott didn't say don't wear mask
anymore he explicitly said the opposite
he said if you want to wear a mask you
should wear a mask
if you're worried about the risk wear a
mask if you don't want to go into an
area with a lot of people who are not
wearing masks don't but biden
things because again there's a binary
logic to people in the democratic party
it's either mandatory
or it is barred those are the only two
choices this means
that taking off the mask means you're a
neanderthal if you take off the mask
by the way i don't even know why joe
biden is wearing masks that he's been
vaccinated
like seriously i understand that he
thinks that this is somehow you know
encouraging people to wear masks the
exact same percentages of people are
wearing masses
were wearing masks before biden was
president i see no evidence of an uptick
in mask wearing
since again this just demonstrates how
dumb the media are the media were like
well you know if we had a president
modeling mascot and many more people
would wear masks
okay show me the percentages seriously
we know how many people were wearing
masks before
is it higher or lower or the same since
biden became president in any case
joe biden said that they were
neanderthals in texas and mississippi
neanderthals now to be fair joe biden
does remember the neanderthals the
neanderthals were some of his best
friends
and he remembers riding a dinosaur you
know he's a real blue-collar guy joe
biden he would clock in for a day at the
rock quarry and then he would slide down
the back of a brontosaurus and get into
his car
and then he would use his actual feet
right move those feet so he could get
home
to wilma but here is uh here is joe
biden
talking about how everyone who disagrees
with him is a neanderthal this is
captain unity over here
i think it's a big mistake i hope
everybody's realized by now
these masks make a difference and the
last thing
the last thing we need is neanderthal
thinking that in the meantime
everything's fine take off your mask
forget it it's still matters it's
critical
critical critical critical that they
follow
the science wash your hands
hot water do it frequently wear
a mask and stay socially distanced
and uh i know you all know that i wish
the heck
some of our elected officials knew it
okay by the way captain follow the
science here still hasn't opened up the
schools
captain follow the science is
responsible for setting up seven federal
mass vaccination sites by the end of
february who's aiming for 100
captain follow the science when i say by
the way that uh joe biden is not with us
he's not with us this was joe biden
yesterday
thank you and i'm happy to take
questions if that's you i'm supposed to
do nance whatever you want me to do
nope if you can't see that i'm very very
thank you and
and nancy if you want me to take
questions if that's what i'm supposed to
do
and then and then they just run the crap
that's all folks
[Music]
i love the person on the button who's
like well we can't let the president
talk off script so let's just hit this
button
and boom fade to black wow that guy's
definitely in control of his own
administration
uh are they gonna let me go to the
denny's now for the early bird dinner
all right now now it's
just get that giant they need the giant
cane with the hook at the end just
just pull joe biden out of there but
he's calling everybody in the
neanderthal so here are the stats
here are the stats okay on the
neanderthal states that have not had a
mass mandate
there are many of these states i'm going
to read to you these states and
their ranking in the death per capita
okay so here we go
you'll see there's a large variance you
ready here we go
alaska is ranked 49th in deaths per
million
49th okay they never had a mass mandate
arizona sixth right so you have 49 and
six
no mass mandate okay florida 27th
georgia 20th idaho 42nd
iowa 16th mississippi 5th missouri 29th
montana 33rd
nebraska 40th north dakota 11th oklahoma
36th south carolina
19th south dakota 8 and tennessee 18th
okay so in other words all over the map
and in fact there are more states that
are in the bottom half
than there are states i believe in the
top half here right because you have one
two three four
five six seven eight eight of those 15
states are in the bottom half of states
by death per million
and yet the idea here is that these are
all bad terrible no good very bad states
right they're neanderthals because after
all they don't have mass mandates
if they had mass mandates presumably
they'll be better off except for the
fact that there is no evidence that this
is
particularly the case there have been
masked mandates all over the world and
you know what those mass mandates did in
la
not much considering that there's a
giant upswing in the fall
a far larger upswing than there was in a
state like florida which did not have a
mass mandate
so what is this really about what this
is really about as always is politics
and control texas and mississippi have
responded to these
idiotic comments by joe biden and beta
o'rourke mississippi governor tate
reeves said president biden said
allowing mississippians to decide how to
protect themselves is neanderthal
thinking
mississippians don't need handlers as
numbers drop they can assess their
choices and listen to experts
i guess i just think we should trust
americans not insult them
and then greg abbott's spokesperson said
the governor was clear in telling texans
coveted has intended
and that all texans should follow
medical advice and safe practices to
continue containing covid
the fact is texas now has the tools and
knowledge to combat covid while also
allowing texans and small businesses to
make their decisions
it is clear from the recoveries the
vaccinations the reduced
hospitalizations and the safe practices
that texans are using that state
mandates are no longer needed we must
now do more to restore livelihood and
normalcy for texans the governor's focus
has been and always will be protecting
the lives
and livelihoods of texans and then later
abbott tweeted the biden administration
is recklessly releasing hundreds of
illegal immigrants who have coveted into
texas
the biden administration must
immediately end this callous act that
exposes texans
and americans to covet so much so much
unity there
from from joe biden and by the way they
are um
they happen to be exactly correct
americans get to decide for themselves
what they wish to do
and that has not changed right they're
going to be areas where there's a lot of
covet hesitancy
and that's okay if you don't want to go
out don't go out
but the idea is that if you have
government control you must use it so
gavin newsom for example
he is now pushing back at all of this he
says it's reckless
absolutely reckless tell me more about
recklessness captain french laundry
tell me more about rekkles gavin newsom
the head of a state the fifth youngest
state in america with the same death per
capita rate as florida the second oldest
state in america please tell me more
gavin newsom who's currently he's so
reckless that dude is now being recalled
in a completely blue state top to bottom
blue state
but it's about something more than that
right it is about the idea that you are
not capable of making
your own decisions or rather you're only
capable of making your own decisions if
you are a particular type of person
if you're not a particular type of
person you're not capable of making your
own decisions so one of the things
that is buried in a lot of the ideology
here for for democrats particularly
is a soft bigotry of low expectations
about americans generally you're not
capable of making your own decisions
but specifically there is a soft bigotry
of low expectations
that attends to minority communities in
the democratic party
right the same motivating factor from
people like jamal bowman
of new york democrat of new york who
says standardized testing is racist
attends when it comes to vaccines and we
have seen a tremendous amount of vaccine
hesitancy unfortunately
in the black and hispanic community and
there is there's a wide differential
in by race in how people are are looking
at the vaccine by pole data by pole data
some 59 of white people say they
definitely will get the vaccine and
another 20
say they will probably get the vaccine
which means that grand totals 79
of white americans say they definitely
will or probably will get the vaccine
okay black america only 67 percent of
black americans say they definitely will
get the vaccine
or probably get the vaccine and by the
way only 37 say they definitely will get
the vaccine which means
that fully 33 of black americans say
they either probably or definitely will
not
get the vaccine from compared to only 21
of white people who say they won't get
the vaccine and only 21 of hispanic
people who say they won't get the
vaccine so the black community has
tremendous
vaccine hesitancy okay that is a real
problem
and yet the answer by the left is that
that is a shortcoming
of government distribution okay that is
not correct if there is differential
behavior and different differential
viewpoints about vaccines
then that is individual behavior and yet
the idea
here is that if you are a that it's only
white i mean remember that michael moore
text right the michael moore tweet was
if you're a texan you don't deserve to
get the vaccine because you're a cove
denier
he would never say that about people who
are literally refusing to get the
vaccine
why because for him the question there
there's a soft bigotry that is inherent
in leftist thought
that suggests that if a white person
makes a bad decision it's on the white
person but if a black person makes a bad
decision
then it is because the system is racist
okay that is not correct we should be
encouraging everyone to make
good decisions this is why all of the
tomfoolery
about the vaccine rollout is a mistake
we should be giving the vaccine to
anyone who will take it at any point at
this point there are many many vaccines
out there
tranching out vaccines based on quote
unquote equity is a foolhardy game
okay instead what we should be doing is
making it available to anyone who wants
one and we should be actively
encouraging people to get one
not writing op-eds in new york times
like charles blow talking about why
black people
are hesitant about vaccines but
encouraging black people to get vaccines
encouraging everybody
to go get the vaccine today and yet
again
there is that generalized idea that the
government must be in complete control
they must mandate things because you
can't take care of yourself
and that but they'll only talk about a
certain type of person who is
who is covet scared or covered shy
right it's it's a it's a it's an obvious
point
and an ugly point but people on the left
will only talk about
coveted shyness when it comes to white
americans they will not talk about covet
china's when it comes to minority
americans
even though the percentages are greater
among minority americans
i mean why you know who should be being
ripped up and down right now not greg
abbott for saying that people should not
be should not be forced to wear masks by
the centralized government because they
are capable of making their own
decisions
the people who should be ripped up and
down right now are people like louis
farrakhan who's literally going out
there and telling
his millions of followers that the
covert vaccine is a vial of death have
you seen any
media coverage of this if a major
conservative figure who had met with a
bunch of members of congress were out
there
literally telling people that the
coveted vaccine was a vial of death you
know that would be the front
of every single newspaper right
conservatives deny
vaccine efficacy and yet here was louis
farrakhan doing just that
democratic members of congress have met
with this guy they continue to meet with
this guy
have you seen a headline about this
here's louis farrakhan who has many many
followers talking about how the copa
vaccine is a vial of death
some of these uh so-called vaccines
yeah it's the nano
particles that
men like dr fauci
have proprietary knowledge of
that allows them to get a patent
for their vial of death
i mean how is that not the headline
right i mean seriously that should be
the headline you want to talk about
overcoming covid we should be talking
about vaccine hesitancy
by the way encouraged for months by
people like kamala harris who literally
said that she would not get a vaccine
just if trump told her to
i mean that that this sort of stuff has
an actual impact
and if you look by race and ethnicity at
why people are not getting the vaccine
right
you can see the the reasons why people
aren't getting the vaccine
what you will see is that among black
americans
a disproportionate number of black
americans don't trust the covet 19
vaccine and a disproportionate number of
black americans are concerned about
the side effects and they plan to wait
and see whether it is safe
and yet the idea here is that it's a
problem with the distribution system
what if it's not a problem with the
distribution system
if the reason that the left wants
centralized control is because they want
control over people
then they really should be clear about
why they want control over people
because right now they tend to blame the
system whenever individual choices are
made they don't like
from people who are allies of theirs but
they blame the individual people
when they're people who they don't like
who don't believe like they do
politically speaking
this is ugly stuff the soft bigotry of
low expectations by the way completely
infuses the democratic party at this
point
you want to talk about democrat-run
cities that have soft bigotry of low
expectations this story came across my
desk this morning
from fox baltimore a shocking discovery
out of a baltimore city high school
where project baltimore has found
hundreds of students are failing
it's a school where a student who passed
three classes
in four years three classes in four
years
not three years in four years three
classes in four years
ranks near the top half of his class
with a 0.13
grade point average tiffany france
thought her son received his diploma
this coming june but after four years of
high school france just learned
her 17 year old must start over he's
been moved back to ninth grade
he's stressed and i am too i told him
i'm probably gonna start crying i don't
know what to do
france told project baltimore why would
he do three more years in school he
didn't fail the school failed him the
school failed at their job
he didn't deserve that france's son
attends
augusta fell's savage institute of
visual arts in west baltimore
his transcripts show he's passed just
three classes in four years
placing him in ninth grade but she
didn't know that until february
she thought her oldest son was doing
well because even though he failed most
of his classes they kept promoting him
his transcript showed he failed spanish
1 and algebra 1 was promoted to spanish
2 and algebra 2. he failed english 2
was passed on to english 3. in his first
three years at augusta fellas the
student failed 22 classes and was late
or absent on 272 days
in those three years only one teacher
requested a parent conference which
france says never happened
no one from the school told france or
son was failing and not going to class
by the way he's still above half of his
class he's ranked 62nd in his class
after
after passing three classes in a grand
total of four years
half of his classmates 58 of them have a
0.13 grade point average
or lower okay how is it
that this is not considered a great
crisis in america
and we're going to focus on woke idiocy
about canceling dr seuss but we're not
going to focus on stuff that actually
betters people's lives
we're not going to focus on individual
responsibility because here's the thing
individual freedom comes with individual
responsibility
we're not even going to focus on true
systems of power that degrade
the lives of individuals nope we're
going to focus on how we can force you
to wear a mask even though that actually
is a risk assessment you yourself should
be doing
and who we should blame namely the
people of texas who we should not blame
namely people who are political allies
of democrats
people's lives actually matter and the
best way to ensure that people live good
lives is to
place the individual responsibility that
comes with freedom upon them
and yet we have an entire system that is
built to do precisely the opposite
precisely the opposite and instead we
just
keep ripping on the system keep ripping
on that system and claiming that
centralized government is going to be
the solution in just a second
we'll get to the centralized government
as solution crowd the the centralized
culture
as as as as the solution crowd we'll get
to that in just one second first
let us talk about your sleep quality so
helix sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete it matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else with helix you're getting a
mattress that you know will be a perfect
way
for the way you sleep everybody's unique
helix knows that they have several
different mattress models to choose from
they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
that are great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
folks so if you're looking for a
mattress you take the quiz you order the
mattress you're matched to the mattress
comes right to your door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to a mattress store again which
sounds pretty fantastic actually helix
is awesome you don't need to take my
word for it
helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020 by both gq
and wired magazine
just head on over to helixsleep.com take
their two minutes sleep quiz they will
match you to a customized mattress
that'll give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10-year warranty you get to try it out
for a hundred nights risk free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you absolutely will
helix is offering up to 200 bucks off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at helixsleep.com go
check them out right now helix
dot com slash bend my wife and i have a
helix lee mattress it is indeed
fantastic
you will love it as much as we do go
check them out right now helixsleep.com
to get up to 200 bucks
off your mattress orders alrighty
earlier this week i had the pleasure of
discussing on this show
minimum wage with representative rocanna
of california it's always a lot of fun
to talk
with people on the other side of the
aisle outside of a safe space
well here's the thing right now in our
current climate every political issue is
a hot button issue
minimum wage is one of those issues and
if you need the knowledge to be able to
debate minimum wage to know why
the minimum wage and raising the minimum
wage is an idiotic economic idea
if you don't feel like going out there
and doing the research yourself i have a
solution for you
i break down the myth of the minimum
wage and others like it on my new daily
wire series debunked every single friday
we drop a new mini documentary last week
we did one on minimum wage this week it
is public sector unions
if you want to get the simple facts and
logic and debunk the leftist claims on
these issues
tune on in debunked it's available
exclusively and only to daily wire
members head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe use code debunked to get 25
off your new membership
that is promo code debunked get 25 off
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
so while people on the left want to
control your entire life and
simultaneously
allow people to just fail inside the
system i mean truly fail inside the
system because we wouldn't want to
require individual responsibility
of them see the thing about failure
within the system is that democrats
right now are perpetual revolutionaries
so it just means they should have more
power
if somebody fails inside the system if
you have a student in baltimore who
graduates three classes in four years
and is still in the top half of his
class well that means that the system
requires more money they require
more control not that people should be
given more individual responsibility
the opposite when new york governor
andrew cuomo is a garbage bag
that means that he should have had more
control it means the government requires
more control speaking of which andrew
cuomo is currently
being essentially forced out of
government they're trying to force him
out
over the sexual harassment allegations
now on the grand scale
of sexual harassment allegations these
ones are not the kind of thing that
generally get
kicked out of office right the worst
thing that he did the worst allegation
against him
is that he called a woman lindsey boylan
up to his office at one point she went
up there and then he kissed her without
her permission
that is that is the the grand sum that
is the
worst thing he did is that a good thing
no of course that's not a good thing
it's a very bad thing right if you work
for a private corporation you'd be fired
but he was elected
that is not really an impeachable
offense because it's not
i mean it would be hard to see that even
as a criminal offense things that are
bad and wrong and ugly
aren't necessarily impeachable as we
have found out many many times in the
past
okay and and cuomo you know grabbing
people by their face in weird ways
and cuomo making awkward jokes about
eating sausages right all that stuff is
yucky
it doesn't necessarily mean that that
guy cannot be governor of new york
anymore that he has lost his capacity
governor of new york what is happening
right now is so perfectly obvious
everyone now realizes the governor cuomo
was a garbage bag
during covet he was terrible his policy
was garbage he got a lot of seniors
killed he lied about it not only to the
press but to his own
party he lied about it to oversight
bodies
and now they're realizing that he's a
liability but they cannot
openly acknowledge that he is a
liability based on his covered behavior
because they were cheering on that exact
behavior so instead they have to find an
ancillary reason to dump him
under the bus they have to find another
reason to get rid of him
but hopefully a reason where they can
report it the media and they can report
it as something new
so they can say well this is new stuff
of course we never reported this last
year because we just didn't know
because if it turns out that he gets
ousted based on kovid we all knew how
bad he was last year
okay so now cuomo is on the hot seat and
he is
he did a presser yesterday in which he
said that he's not going to go first he
denied
inappropriate touching in any way there
is an investigation now going on
in the office of latisha james the ag of
the state who i'm sure has her eye on
the gubernatorial seat here is
here's andrew cuomo i never
touched anyone inappropriately
i never touched anyone inappropriately
i never knew at the time
that i was making anyone feel
uncomfortable i never knew
at the time i was making anyone feel
uncomfortable and
i certainly never ever
meant to offend anyone
or hurt anyone or cause
anyone any pain and then he went on he
talked about how in his culture he likes
to touch people's faces and stuff
so i guess he and joe biden come from
the exact same culture because joe biden
also likes to inappropriately touch
people cuomo then said i'm not going to
resign under any of these circumstances
again the reason that andrew cuomo's on
the chopping block right now has nothing
to do with this behavior
just recognize that this is all a
misdirect it is all a way for the media
to escape their own culpability
in promoting this douchebag for a full
year well old people were dying in
nursing homes and he was covering it up
recognize that right now what we are
watching is a sham and a ruse
it is a fake reason for getting rid of
andrew cuomo the real reason he should
be gotten rid of is because he probably
should be prosecuted for covering up
what happened in the nursing homes
in new york anyway cuomo says i'm not
going to resign and by the way
for the behavior that's been described
we probably shouldn't resign here he is
i'm not going to resign i work for the
people of the state of new york they
elected me
and i'm going to serve the people of the
state of new york and by the way we have
a full plate
we have coveted we have recovery we have
rebuilding
we have a teetering new york city we
have a terrible financial picture
we have to do vaccines so no
i'm going to do the job the people of
the state elected me to do
okay so he's not leaving he's telling
you he's not going
he's the best man he's ever known that's
it dream girl's reference there for you
in any case
new york's democrats they're like well
we would love to throw them under the
bus
so democratic assemblyman thomas
sambananti he's a democrat he said cuomo
should reside now let's be real about
this again the reason that he should
resign is not the reason they're all
citing for him to resign
here's ebenante earlier today i called
on the governor to resign
i believe that it's important
that the governor be above reproach
he has to have the respect necessary to
lead new york i believe the governor is
distracted and cannot give his
undivided attention to continue safely
navigating new yorkers through the
ongoing
pandemic and i think his whole situation
is a distraction
to the serious conversations necessary
to complete an on-time budget just a
quick note if this had happened in the
middle of last year everybody would have
ignored it
okay everybody in the media would have
downplayed it they would have said these
allegations are are not particularly
serious
he has denied the allegations and they
all would have moved on how do we know
because
there were allegations that were made
that were much more serious about joe
biden and the media basically blew them
off
so it is all just a matter of how useful
these politicians are to them
andrew cuomo has lost his usefulness
because it has come out now what an
incompetent buffoon he has
he is and not only is he useful not
useful anymore he is embarrassing to
them
and so they have found another reason to
get rid of andrew cuomo and yet their
answer to all of this is that andrew
cuomo still was the greatest governor in
all of human history when it came to
covet
that we need more centralized control
and that anybody who says that you
should use your own brain in determining
your risk or how to educate your child
for that matter
or how you ought to raise your child all
of those people are wrong
we need to raise your child for you we
need to mandate
things from the top down because you
can't handle it yourself
you just can't and if you try to handle
it yourself then that means that you're
in league with people who want human
sacrifice
and who want death and who want to spare
if you trust this bunch of clowns at the
top of your government
with pretty much anything i gotta doubt
your own sanity at this point
these people have been wrong on
virtually all of the things they've
given you a bunch of conflicting advice
every system that they run with the
exception of the military is a giant
fail and yet there are people who
believe the solution to all this to give
these
jackasses more power it's truly an
astonishing thing and then they believe
these people are their moral leaders to
boot
which is even more astonishing if you
like freedom
then at a certain point we should
probably stand up for it and if we've
now gotten to the point in the pandemic
where we're on the downswing and where
it is perfectly clear that the vaccines
are being rolled out at extraordinary
rates
and we are not looking at any threat to
the hospitalizations and the icus
at that point it seems like freedom
should be legal again should it not in
fact it never became illegal in the
first place
and and we should remember this for the
future now that it should not have taken
a year for us to get to the point
of saying the exact same thing that
florida said all the way back last
summer which is
take your best available precautions and
then live your life because
every day that you live is a day that
has been lived and that day that you
have lived
is no longer on the record of days going
forward available to you so every day
that you spend in lockdown
or obeying government edicts on the
basis of bad information
is a day of which you were robbed don't
let them rob
don't let them rob you of your time just
don't let them do it
alrighty coming up a little bit later we
have an hour more of the ben shapiro
show and coming up soon is the mount
wall show it airs at 1 30 pm eastern be
sure to check it out over at
dailywear.com
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavel wydowsky
editing is by adam's psy events audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show